the standards in which people want from
companies is completely
completely impossible for most companies
they may be good at
the environment but they're bad at wages
they may like companies are
a convoluted animal just like people
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
and we're going to just jump right in
first up we've got none other than kevin
o'leary
he's not only the star of abc's shark
tank
he's an active photographer a watch
collector
guitarist and author of three
number one best-selling books welcome
kevin great to be here thank you so much
kevin it's a real real real pleasure to
have you here um
first of all have you done through this
pandemic both on a personal level and
maybe
a macro kind of like a business level
you know because this pandemic has
created a lot of
you know winners and a lot of losers
it's been very all over the place
you have a vast portfolio you know how
are you
and then kama how is your business world
well
you know gary that is the question for
everybody in america today and you're
right there are winners and losers but
you know personally i'm adjusting just
like you are to living the world in a
digital way just
every day i communicate as we are right
now and
all of my companies i have over 50
portfolio companies now
um have gone through this incredible
transition to what i call the digital
pivot
america 2.0 the ones that have survived
um you know first of all we've we've
gone through this
seven months now have been able to tell
a story online
shifted direct to consumer sales become
very proficient at logistics
and have been able to just take away
what they lost from
retail sales and sold it direct to
customers so in this
crazy outcome that i could have never
foreseen 80
of the portfolio even though revenues
are down
are actually ahead of free cash flow
forecasts why
because they've gone from just doing 10
direct to consumer
to doing 40 to 50 direct to consumer at
almost 100 gross margin
and they've saved their companies now
the ones in travel the ones in
entertainment the movie theater
businesses
uh the events those those the live event
stuff
i'm sorry they're going to zero and
that's 20 of my portfolio but 80
that's fantastic they're going to make
it so let's frame up the question that
this whole show is going to be about and
we have an incredible lineup starting
with you where where is the customer's
attention
how do you synthesize that question and
what is the answer well never in our
lives gary have we had the opportunity
to have such a captive customer
they are sitting at home just like you
and i are they're looking to be
entertained communicated with
they are willing and able to purchase
products and services
but they want it done conveniently and
delivered directly to them
they are not going to go get it anymore
this is the
digitization of america in a very fast
way
and what i've learned and this is really
binary
i used to have this joke gary i used to
tell people what career should you have
and i'd say well there's three careers
if you're going to go to college and
invest in yourself
engineering engineering and engineering
but now you know who i'm hiring story
writers
videographers photographers editors
i'm i'm having to compete all around the
world are hiring some people in israel
in italy and france to cut video
because all of my companies are telling
stories on their websites
and so we have now empowered a whole new
generation of artists who are doing
phenomenally well
that i would have never guessed
storytelling direct communications with
your customer
compelling them to watch that 1920 39 49
second video
that communicates what your product or
service is is what the successful
companies are doing
and we are spending millions of dollars
doing this digital pivot
obviously because of dragon's den and
then shark tank you're you have a
personal brand
how have you the human because you're
talking you know obviously
as you can imagine i'm listening to the
first five minutes of this conversation
i've been spending the last 11 years
building a communications death star
to do everything you just talked about
because i basically believed that the
internet was going to squeeze the middle
everything was going to be direct to
consumer whether that's ott or
e-commerce and that the ability to
storytell and run the arbitrage on the
distributions
was actually the game so i like those
chess moves of how they played out to me
i'm curious because i'm sure a lot of
people who are watching are curious
right now
what about you yourself within social
media
have you in these nine months because
i'm sure you've been busy
helping mentoring like i'm sure you're
on constantly on
calls with entrepreneurs of these 50
plus businesses
but what about you and your own personal
brand have you picked up a platform
have you started to use linkedin from a
content standpoint
have you downloaded tick tock where are
you the man
you the shark you the people where do
you sit personally right now
with with social or content creation
whether first
party because you grab the phone and do
it or whether you live a little bit of
the game i play i have
drock ironically is here for the first
time in seven months have somebody
producing for you you the personal brand
what's the production around that if
anything you know gary you
are the role model for guys like me you
got it right you guessed it right the
middle did get squeezed out there's no
question
and i really got involved in social
about two and a half years ago and i
hired a team of producers editors and
storytellers
to work within my own production company
larry productions
and what i learned and this is the
paramount maybe
maybe i'll give you credit for this
because certainly watching you
you cannot [ __ ] people you can't
lie to them you have to be totally
transparent
whether that's good bad or ugly you got
to tell the truth
that is what a personal brand is built
on the minute it's almost like the
analogy i use
i teach this stuff now i'm here in
boston i do i used to do
lectures in person but now i do them
virtually at harvard and mit
and temple and notre dame and i talk
about this stuff
primarily the graduating course of
business students and engineers about
entrepreneurship
it's like dating you know when you fall
in love
and you meet somebody and you're just
empowered by that magic
moment and i draw this analogy all the
time you just it's so wonderful and
everybody should fall in love with
whoever it's going to be but then as
time passes things change
and maybe a year or two later you're
thinking about
cheating okay and you do
now you have a decision to make after
you've done that do you tell the truth
to your significant other or do you keep
it a secret
and here's why i bring it up for
business you're going to get caught
one hundred percent of the time when you
cheat you're going to get caught because
you didn't tell the truth
your significant other can never look at
you the same again
you've lost 50 percent of the equity in
that relationship forever it may not
break up
you may go on but it will never forever
the same
yeah and in business the first time you
lie to your customers your
constituencies your shareholders
you lose 50 of the equity forever better
to tell the truth and take the hit
and the ownership and transparency and
intent around the i'm sorry
the the that's such that's absolutely
right everything out of your mouth comma
there's also the half pregnant sorry
and there's the real sorry and i think
corporations
the standards in which people want from
companies is completely
completely impossible for most companies
they may be good at
the environment but they're bad at wages
they may like companies are
a convoluted animal just like people and
this thought
that you don't understand how to say
sorry when you're trying to fix
something
people would rather dance look over
there a bird instead of owning it
and to your point in that lack of
apology creates more damage sometimes
than even the event itself
yes and that's exactly it and i tell all
my ceos now
look do not lie to the customers don't
lie to your employees don't lie to me
don't lie to anybody your shareholders
even take the pain
take the hit admit the mistake you made
and you will build a relationship
particularly with customers
what we're learning online is if you
have a direct relationship with a
customer and you're honest with them
and you tell them hey the product's
going to be delayed or sorry you got a
bad product will replace it will give
your money back whatever it is
that communication ends up being very
very valuable over time
those customers stay loyal we've learned
that a hundred fold in our companies now
and now we're in across the portfolio
we're now at 48
directive revenue to customer that's
magic gary
that's friggin magic that because that's
100 gross margin business
one of the uh we've run out of time
we're going to move on
we really appreciate your time but one
of the fun topics
in the chess game of what you're talking
about is channel conflict
for the people that still rely on a lot
of business from retail
as retailers watching them go around
them and that is going to be
interesting battles of the next decade
of business let's talk about that next
time my friend thank you so much thank
you
kevin bye-bye youtube watcher what's up
it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you